[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [Applause]
[Music]
my first time in Hollywood I came to the
Hollywood Walk of Fame and I I came to
Hollywood Boulevard walked down the Walk
of Fame
had no idea one day that I'd be getting
a star of my own I was wearing this
sweatshirt at the time I was 16 this is
my favorite hoodie in high school and I
still have it today I saw that okay I
Gotta Wear it it fits Avril Lavigne
having a full circle moment as she
celebrates her star on the Hollywood
Walk of Fame
reflecting on her career journey and
sharing the advice she'd give to her
younger self just work hard and know who
you are be real then
authentic and believe in yourself
because anything is possible I'm so
happy to have met you and be a part of
your journey as a fan and as a friend
and
um you're so important and
this the star is a microcosm of
everything that you are doing and have
done for us
um
this is your day this is your this is
this is your era you you your songs will
live far past any of our lifetimes so
congratulations on
being Avril Lavigne
Machine Gun Kelly got up and spoke and
then this really meant a lot to me to
have my friends here with
we write songs we go on tour together
and so we're just sort of celebrating it
all together I mean I worked with the
most incredible people like the coolest
musicians on this my latest album love
sucks John falvin Matson Machine Gun
Kelly Travis Barker and John Feldman
spoke I'm so grateful to give Avril
Lavigne her Hollywood Walk of Fame Star
as for what's next well expect some
collabs
don't call me baby I love it when you
hate me I mean I definitely hit a few of
them on this album that's for sure
yeah but I can't tell you I do have I
have a song Dropping in like a couple
months with somebody
[Music]